you got to be the hardest workers in the
room and don't the opportunity out don't
alienate yourself from other people's
success or downfalls or problems educate
yourself to it best piece of advice I'm
not here to change what you're doing or
tell you that you're doing it wrong I'm
just simply giving information you can
use it or not your life is going to be
your life no matter what if all of our
lives are going to be the same this
world would be stupid maybe some of the
stuff that's worked for me might work
for you this idea and this notion that
you could be anything you want you can
accomplish anything you want the thing
that has worked for me is to
remember the hard times